breaking Biden doj finds Elon Musk 350
thousand dollars after he refuses to
give them access to Trump's Twitter
account The District Court held accent
contempt for missing the deadline and
the social media platform was fined 350
000 I think for Elon it's probably a
drop in the Hat but uh wow massive
credit to uh to uh Elon and ax for
basically telling the government to go
uh shove off we were uh we were talking
about this a little bit earlier and and
redid mention back when uh Apple told
the FBI to go piss up a rope when the
FBI was trying to get uh get them to
unlock a a terrorists
but then they eventually just figured
out a way to break in yeah but at least
Apple didn't help them do right you know
which is and credit to them and this to
me is kind of the same kind of situation
like uh credits to Twitter because
anyone that pushes back against the feds
when it comes to this type of thing I
think is a good is good so we also need
to protect that Twitter account at all
costs Donald Trump's Twitter oh yeah
well that belongs I'm of natural history
I mean of American History so he needs
to get back on it he uh he truth we have
this uh truth from real Donald Trump
reposted by election wizard he says just
found out that crooked Joe Biden's doj
secretly attacked my Twitter account
making it a point not to let me know
about this major hit on my civil rights
my political opponent is going crazy
trying to infringe on my campaign for
president nothing like this has ever
happened before does the First Amendment
still exist the deranged Jack Smith tell
the unselects to destroy and delete all
evidence these are dark days in America
I completely agree the the sitting
president
is trying to he this is beyond Watergate
what is this Joe Biden just tried to
steal private Communications from his
main political rival yes let me just
repeat that for everybody we now know
and Elon Musk obstructed this Joe Biden
running for president just tried to
steal the private Communications
unconstitutionally from Donald Trump
from his private account and only
because of Elon Musk they're obstructed
incredible
I think technically and I could be wrong
Twitter owns that account so it's
technically uh Elon musk's data and
account so they'd be if they were
stealing it they'd be stealing it from
Elon but it looks like they asked him
for it so it wouldn't have been theft if
that sounds like something the NSA would
say well I think I don't own any of our
social media any reasonable person would
argue that our data belongs to us I
would like it to but I think legally at
this point it doesn't but it should in
some on some sites maybe it does if it's
in their terms a lot of sites want to
own your stuff I gotta tell you I I
don't care what ridiculous psychotic
totalitarian Nazi BS the government
tries to argue about why they have a
right to to take my private
Communications they don't the Fourth
Amendment extends to what is my private
Communications and they can make all the
arguments in the world that when you
when you transmitted the message over
Twitter you gave that message to Twitter
now yeah that's a BS argument from
Psychopaths who are trying to bypass our
constitution would be like if you went
into somebody's house and had a Converse
station with somebody else in that house
and they were recording you in their
house and then you left like technically
that person's that owned the house would
own that communication now that's kind
of like Twitter it's more like you have
a it's more like you uh bought you you
rent a mailbox at a big so so out in the
middle of nowhere people don't have
mailbox in front of their houses
depending on where you live they'll
actually have a mailbox building where
everyone goes and collects their mail
despite having private houses they go to
one spot so you know where we are up in
the mountains these mail trucks can't
get on some of these roads
so we'll be more like they said that
mailbox isn't actually yours it's
property of the post office therefore
anything inside of inside of it is our
fair game to open and read I think the
post office can open and read your mail
they need probable cause the fourth
amendment protects us so I will make the
fair point that they're saying a judge
ordered this but that means very little
to me when it is the president trying to
steal the private Communications of his
chief political rival
that's a whole degree of f'd up yeah I
mean it just because there's a political
campaign going on or just because Donald
Trump is a Persona non-grad it doesn't
mean that the federal government can
just look into his private
Communications and there is an
expectation of privacy that you that
people have when they use platforms like
this you know that's why they call them
private messages that's a big mistake
yeah that's why you need to encrypt your
messages and have end-to-end encryption
anything that is unencrypted is viewable
by every government on well most of the
governments on Earth I would imagine at
this point you're totally right but the
average person doesn't you know but
that's like experience is not excuse you
know that's like saying The Government
Can spy on you unless you build a house
inside of a faraday cage it's like no if
you don't have conditions is to stop
them from doing it like it's if you
don't have curtains on your windows no
Constitution is going to stop the cops
from looking inside your that's that's
not a fair Affair analogy because when
you're sending a private message you are
not the average person does not believe
they're standing nude in front of a
window they think the curtains are up so
it would be more like the government has
goggles that can see through your
curtains and said well it's your fault
for only having regular curtains
it's like what am I supposed you got to
put up lead curtains you do you do right
because the Chinese governmentable well
I guess you are the foreign we're
talking about the United States
government trying to steal Trump's
Communications it's any anybody can do
it any government could do it and that's
not my concern my concern is the U.S
government violating the rights of
American citizens and Joe Biden trying
to steal Communications from Trump to
cheat an election
well I mean I think you did you just
point out it's not he got a judge's the
judge side it means very little when the
doj Joe Biden is targeting his political
opponent I don't care criminally
charging Trump I don't care they've
crossed the line they're engaged in
Civil War I don't disagree with you but
I have no empathy for people that
continue to text on their phones with
proprietary software to type on direct
messages on Twitter and YouTube without
saying this stuff like that is trackable
data through your head I have no empathy
I have tons of sympathy for people who
eat Splenda and drink fluoride and do a
whole bunch of other really awful things
because the government tells them it's
fine yeah well they should because there
are there are people who should know
these things but it's not the job of the
average person who's a plumber or a
carpenter or who works an insurance
company to read the news and do the
research every day that's what we do and
so we try to inform them we try to tell
people hey man you gotta encrypt your
messages hey you got to eat healthy you
gotta exercise and you got to pay
attention to what's going on to the best
of your abilities but the point is the
average person yeah wow people are out
there building houses okay they're
working eight 12-hour days they're not
gonna go online and research fluoride
for 27 years to figure out what's going
on with the water or atrazine or or
sucralose or other stuff like that so
they come to shows like this and we do
our best to inform them to the best of
our abilities so I do have sympathy for
people they think their messages are
private because it's only between them
and another person if there was a big
red stop sign on the on the thing that
said anyone can see this they would take
it much more seriously but they're not
being told that they're being misled
outside of all of that the most
important thing to consider it doesn't
matter whether or not Donald Trump can
be spot on by China or Australia or any
other country it doesn't matter if
private messages are not secure what
matters is even if I paint a big picture
and I put it in my bedroom the federal
government does not have a right to come
and take it without a warrant in this
instance the chief political rival is
being targeted by the sitting president
for political purposes you're not going
to make an argument about warrants in
that case the Constitution has been
ripped to shreds and Joe Biden is
cheating to try and steal 2024.
I think it's interesting that the
federal government often uses foreign
governments as a scare tactic to let
them just you know have open season on
your uh private messages too like the
restrict act that's what the the tick
tock ban is what it was being sold as
because China's harvesting our data or
whatever but then the restrict Act was
just basically a patriot act for all
social media companies five Eye spy Club
this is what they do
the United States Canada New Zealand
Australia the UK
each of them go to each other and say it
is illegal for us to spy on our citizens
you spy on them then share the data with
us and now it's allowed
that's how they bypass our human rights
and you know that they they've their
stories that I've heard that they're are
people that abuse it like dudes are
asking people hey can you watch my
ex-girlfriend and that kind of stuff
like you know oh yeah yeah I think
there's no Revelations showed that right
yeah because they because they if you're
you know if you're working in the Intel
community and stuff you're gonna end up
getting friendly with other you know
with other uh other countries with other
people in in the Intel Community for
other countries I've worked on the
social media from the inside and it
feels like walking down dark alleys at
night in big cities like don't do it
don't post your data publicly in direct
messages on Twitter if it's not
encrypted do not do it because you're
putting yourself in a vulnerable
position if you do that and if you're
taking advantage of yeah you can blame
the victim but like like oh she had it
coming because what she was wearing but
like it you just don't go down if you if
you continue to go down those dark
alleys I mean I just don't have sympathy
for those people if if you know that
there's a a risk involved but you're
gonna do it anyway just because you're
lazy or you don't care I screw off like
you deserve it like eat it I don't know
what I tell you reality is reality like
if you're not going to protect yourself
you're not gonna be protected
yep
the problem with end-to-end encryption
is that if the person on the other end
of your message shares that message with
somebody uh well that's true that's not
private yeah that's true if you go to
someone and say hey don't tell anybody
but you know X Y and Z and then they go
hey everybody X Y and Z secret was
meaningless but uh elon's doing a great
job I think he's working on end-to-end
encryption for all direct messages I'm
not sure if they've implemented yet but
it's probably for this reason
I think Elon would prefer not to get
fined you know 350 million 350 uh 350
000 and it's easier if everything's just
encrypted he can go here you go and it's
a bunch of exactly he doesn't have the
thing to give them so they can't find
him that's how mines does it they don't
hold the keys only the keys only belong
to the people that are sending the
messages thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time